well that's happened in the last 10
years
it's a miracle I'm even sitting here now
I got a second chance
I'm going to take advantage of that
but I need you with me Pete
you're gonna Heal the World
guys this is my best friend Harry hey
good to meet you good job huh
still gonna have time for tutoring
figure it out
I didn't know there were bears in these
Woods
I have another name for you Craven
what kind of a hunt
I'm just a call away
you know what you took for me
all miles talks about is how to be a
better Spider-Man
how to help you the hell is going on
with me he's not himself go help him
it was our dream
I'm not
we're going to kill the world
PlayStation
what's up everybody hey let's get some
let's get some more energy up in here
what's up everybody what about that
trailer though
[Music]
fully
[Applause]
oh all right bully all right all right
what's up everybody welcome just had to
get that out of the way I know what
you're here to see excitement
how y'all doing hey what's up
all right guys well welcome to the
Spider-Man 2 panel we are so excited to
be here my name is Dorian Parks I am the
owner and founder of an organization
called Geeks of color where you love
promoting diversity
so enough about me though like I've been
coming here for about past 10 years or
so waiting in the Hall age line so it
feels pretty surreal to be right here
right now man like I love Spider-Man
love miles so these characters have been
so close to my heart so just can't wait
to just talk more about Spider-Man so
that being said enough about me let's
jump into this amazing panel that we
have here first we have senior creative
director Brian anahar
hey everyone
in your art director
be your narrative director John Paquette
senior game director Brian Smith
BP and creative director of Marvel games
or creative director of Marvel games yes
Bill Rose man
[Applause]
already Yuri lowenthal AKA Peter Parker
before before the camera
quick
I've been hearing about the strike uh we
are here this weekend uh but we we stand
with uh you know in solidarity with with
our our brothers and sisters and and
everybody in the wga
um
in the WJ in SAG we are here because uh
we are able to be here because we're
under different contract for games
but that might not last forever so
um if you want to uh you know learn more
about strike and everything's going on
the fight's going on
um it's this is not the place we're here
to talk about Spider-Man but there's a
great panel on Saturday morning at 10
30. uh all your questions will be
answered and or you could go to
navavoices.org I just wanted to to let
you know we're happy to be here but we
we do support everything that's going on
thank you yeah
next we have Naji Jitter AKA Miles
Morales
the lovely and talented Laura Bailey AKA
Mary Jane
and last but not least the horror icon
legend Tony Todd
AKA Venom
let's get let's give one more Round of
Applause to our amazing panelists that
we have here today let's get going out
all right well we got a lot to talk in
we've got a lot to talk about so first
Brian my first question for you is where
do we find Peter MJ Harry and miles at
the beginning of Marvel Spider-Man 2 now
that we're in the the third installment
of the franchise well you could find us
all in the back being late to the panel
because we were watching the story
trailer as you guys were all watching it
backstage first off so
um yeah I think it is what's really
great about this game is that we're
gonna pick up roughly nine to ten months
after um the events of Miles Morales
which even played it it's an amazing
video game by The Talented team and
what's really great is we kind of have
Pete miles they're a well-oiled machine
they're a great team they lean on each
other they really support each other and
they're really protecting the city but
same time there's a lot of things going
on in their life outside the mask uh
miles is applying to college and trying
to figure out how to raise college essay
and you know Pete starting his uh
teaching career and then you have MJ who
is still at the bugle but um under a new
leadership with the return of J Jonah
Jameson at The Daily News
[Applause]
and then bill so my next question is for
you so what can you talk about the
dynamic of these characters and how
working with Insomniac they're keeping
the authentic authenticity of the DNA of
these the core of these characters while
still making it their own awesome thank
you for the question first of all thank
you for coming yeah
so
so you know the heart of our spider
group these characters they're a lot
like the people behind the scenes uh
that you know we all are the best when
we are together and when it comes to
being authentic what's so fun
is that
sometimes you get on this side of the
desk right but then you realize everyone
here we're all fans too right so
everyone knows and loves these
characters
um and so it all comes from the heart uh
it all comes from we're looking at the
comics we're looking at everything we're
looking at where our game is where it
has come before and where it's going so
this whole team it all comes from love
uh the and then the characters of course
are interacting in different ways uh uh
as as Brian said they're all at a point
where they got to make big decisions
uh and when something huge drops into it
those decisions kind of get fractured
and cracked and they have to rely on
each other to get through the growing
Darkness
absolutely and just piggybacking all
that can you talk about as this is the
third game in the the franchise can you
talk about the collaborative process
working with Insomniac and how that's
evolved over time well what's so awesome
um and this is actually before and after
the whole pandemic is we're about 10
minutes away from each other
and so we would uh get together all the
time to look at things just have lunch
talk about stuff talk about our favorite
Spider-Man stuff
um and so I think that leads to what you
feel in the game the authenticity so so
together working all together we're all
one team uh we all love the characters
we're all our goal is to make something
that you love that when you play it you
say this was made by fans for fans
absolutely
this is a love letter to these
characters this is the game I always
wanted and now my friends my family can
all see why all of us were huge fans of
these characters for years and years so
it all comes from Love and and we come
together
like the hashtag says be greater
together oh yeah
and John my next question is for you
with the the new villains that we've
seen in this this game confirmed
villains with Craven Venom and lizard he
talked narratively why you felt those
choices for those villains were
important uh yeah well I mean
boy what a trailer huh uh all those all
those villains like there's a lot
um but for us it really started with
Craven uh he's our Catalyst for for the
story right like he you know before the
game starts he's Halfway Around the
World being Craven uh hunting uh trying
to find the ultimate prey and he watched
from afar as the events of the first two
games occurred
um and he decided you know what there's
a lot of stuff going on in New York City
that that might be my new hunting ground
so
um like I said Craven's a catalyst for
for everything happening when he comes
to to New York City
you know a lot of things start start
going wrong uh you know uh we we have
lizard
um coming coming out we have uh the
Symbiote uh coming out
um and and as you saw briefly in in that
trailer
um miles is forced to to come face to
face with the Mr negative the the guy
who killed his dad so there's a lot of
drama uh that that's happening
um in this game absolutely and just into
my next question for you so I think one
of the things fans really appreciate
about both of the games is just the
environment just lived in cities that it
feels it feels like a character in its
own so can you talk about how you
elevated that with this new game
especially with the PS5 technology and
the new locations that we'll see like
with Coney Island and queens and stuff
like that
to our fans
miles is from Brooklyn
um
not only does it increase the gameplay
space so there's a lot more uh places
for you to swing to but it also has some
really cool obviously Marvel landmarks
as well as New York landmarks for
example I know in Queens everybody has
wanted to visit Aunt May's house and
perhaps we'll see where Peter lives I
know a lot of fans had wanted to
interact with that space so just be able
to like walk in and see where he lives
is incredible oh and there's a picture
of Aunt May's house
um the other thing that's really cool is
it's introducing a lot of cool landmarks
like the East River so as you can see in
our gameplay uh trailer that we produced
a while back you can now chase the
lizards on the East River which is
awesome and personally for me I just
love seeing the Brooklyn Bridge the
Williamsburg Bridge and being able to
just swing across the water it's an
incredible experience
lovely and I got a follow-up question
for you Jason to just speaking of the
the R2 Spider-Man Heroes that we have
can you talk about the suit upgrade the
suit designs and and your choices with
that oh
the heroes evolve it's really important
to evolve their suits so when you look
at Peter you know he's been through a
lot obviously with his mentor turning
out to be Doc Ock but he's also grown
really confident in his powers so what
we did was we just made his suit feel a
bit more confident so the biggest thing
you'll probably notice is the color you
know the colors are more vibrant the red
is that cherry red the blue is more
saturated so it really pops off the
screen and I feel like that's that
confidence that Peter has as a
Spider-Man and then with Miles you know
obviously if you played the miles game
he's just gone off of this adventure and
challenge that he faced with tinkerer
and that also reflects how he's also
coming to his power and feeling more
confident so we just made a suit more
sophisticated and and clean so we made a
lot of the red details a little bit
skinnier we added the red stripe to his
arms and then we added some of that red
detailing to his feet so it just makes
him feel overall more sophisticated and
more confident which is exactly where he
is when you see him with his new powers
love to hear it and Ryan my next
question for you just following up with
the new locations can you talk about how
the the new traversal techniques that
we're implementing in this game affected
what you approach your approach to this
and how you elevated it sure I mean one
of the interesting things with Brooklyn
and Queens is you're not always
surrounded by skyscrapers anymore and so
we thought what's a really great
opportunity something we've seen on
comic book covers we've seen it in the
movies we can add the web wings and that
that was really changed how we look at
traversal swinging is always our
Spider-Man Core that's where we come
from but what we did is design the web
Wing so that we could integrate them and
weave them in with swinging you gain
height and you build speed between
swinging and the web wings and you go
back and forth and really kind of weave
your way through the city it's really
fun in Brooklyn in Queens there are some
lower spaces there are some new spaces
but you have you have to get between
Manhattan and uh the other boroughs by
crossing the river so that's another
opportunity where we could really uh
well we added these things called jet
streams or wind tunnels you really build
speed there and they just shoot you
right along when you're in the web Wings
it's really fun and you know it's one of
the chances for us to really push the
power of the PS5 there and like hit a
level of speed that we hadn't had in the
previous game it's really added a new
dimension to what we can do with
traversal and just speaking about
pushing the power of the PS5 can you
talk a little bit more about the the
mechanic the game mechanics with this
especially with the Symbiote and how the
the techniques and combos are are
evolving yeah sure for us when we looked
at it and what are we going to do with
the Symbiote in gameplay it's really
about power and transformation and we
saw that I think in the Gameplay trailer
we did a few weeks ago when Peter does
his special symbiote moves there's a a
really big shift to what he does and
sometimes he applies power to just one
single enemy six and two over the wall
or something like that sometimes he
really changes shape to travel across
the space and launch people in the air
so I think it's about that power and
transformation that we can get from the
Symbiote and then we can bring it to
life with uh the PS5 and just speaking
of awesome yo Brian I'm coming back to
you can you talk about how the this be
able to evolves and it's an important
part of the The Narrative and overall
story of this game yeah I mean it's it
drives a lot I mean we you know Bill is
talking about how we were you know how
he worked so close together I remember
being in that office when we were
talking about what our kind of post-game
scenes were going to be we knew right
away well we're gonna have miles with by
getting getting the spider powers but we
talked about
well what do we want to do yeah the
second one Spider-Man two because and we
said well what about the Symbiote and we
knew we were going to make that decision
it was like we're going all in you know
we have to go all in so it really drives
you know you saw as Ryan was explaining
about the gameplay but in terms of
Peter's Story how that involves
um you know his best friend Harry
um how it affects those around him
um and how he changes
um you know throughout the game and his
relationship so it's just it really you
know back um when we released the first
game I said you know people ask why
isn't the black suit why isn't the black
suit I said we're gonna do we're gonna
ever do that too it deserves its own
game and that's what you're going to see
in Spider-Man 2 what we deserve it
deserves its own storyline speaking of
symbiote I'm passing it to you Yuri how
can you speak to how the Symbiote has
affected Peter no I don't want to get
you in trouble with you spoiling things
right I mean the cool the cool thing is
is I can say anything I want on this
panel and then just blame it on the
Symbiote later
um
you know
I don't know what the big deal is I
think the Symbiote makes Peter a better
Spider-Man
come on guys don't you think don't you
think this is yeah I mean he is he he is
definitely you know taken with that
power
and very little responsibility actually
uh you know as it uh as it goes but
um it's it's a back and forth room it's
it's a lot of power for him to deal with
and on one hand it's uh you know it's
great and uh on the other hand it's uh
it's hard because
you know people get hurt yeah can you
speak to how it affects the people in
his life the relationships in his life
like with Miles and MJ yeah well you
know when something come becomes more
important to you than the people in your
life
relationships uh break you know they
they falter and um if the the strength
of that thing is so powerful that you
can't you know you know just
you know yell at somebody and then oh
I'm sorry you know I was having a bad
day
um then uh you know it's uh it takes a
lot more to come back so
that will uh it gets complicated for for
Pete and the people around him oh yeah
we can't wait to see how it affects them
throughout the game so my next question
for you though not miles nausea
what's going on so we do see we do we
see Mr negative in this trailer so can
you just briefly talk a little bit about
how he's still coping with the effects
of his game and dealing with the loss of
his father man well y'all seen Mao's
trajectory you know and just with
everything that he's been through with
his family and his friends and just
getting into this new world that he's
you know being introduced to but he's
now owning this this power but you know
um coming back to Martin Lee man that
was something big I didn't think that we
would uh revisit that because we had a
lot of emotions on set yeah yeah man I
was raised by a single mom so you know I
don't have my dad in my life so that was
a kind of a boom right there so we we
kept it right there but uh we we
delivered some some great things for
y'all and you kind of but can you
elaborate a little bit more on how miles
is really coming into his own especially
after his game like he he's not no
longer looking at Peter as his
Apprentice but more of an equal now with
his powers and his abilities yes it's
still big bro this is still big bro all
right show me the ropes
P would not I mean miles would not be
anywhere without Pete so y'all know that
but um man you know it was it was great
you know I still look up to Pete so you
know it's still it's still an ongoing
you know we learned the physicality but
then you got to learn you know just the
mannerisms and getting into that manhood
of of carrying on that power with that
responsibility love to hear it and my
last question because we touched on it
as well but his powers and his abilities
how is he really we see them evolving
and we we see him he has a couple new
abilities so how is he really coming
into his own with that with his
abilities oh we got some stuff coming
for y'all
oh
we got some stuff coming for y'all y'all
y'all get ready October 20th you're
gonna be surprised you're gonna be
shocked you're going to be on your feet
you're going to be screaming yeah be
crying you're gonna be laughing so y'all
get ready man we got some powerful stuff
coming for y'all I apologize to
employers everywhere because I hear a
lot of people going I've already booked
you know time off from work you know
from around October 20th for like three
days right well man we love to hear her
so I'm passing it to you Miss Miss
lovely Laura Bailey we have MJ in the
house so can you talk about what are her
Ambitions in this game and how her her
storyline has evolved from when we last
saw her
um well I'll look at her isn't she just
lovely
um yeah I think she's coming to her own
a lot more I think she's understanding
who she is as a reporter and as a writer
a lot more
um you know she spent a lot of time away
from Peter and simcaria
um and she's she am I allowed to say
this
um you know she's writing
um
and their relationship is more
comfortable now you know they've been
together she understands what he's doing
and um
it's interesting to get to see
how everything that he's going through
uh affects her perception of that God
I respect and respected and can you
elaborate a little bit about it seems
now it's more of a team Dynamic with p
with Peter with Miles and with MJ so can
you elaborate a little bit more on that
and how that Dynamic works now yeah
then in his
Lee and and now we get to see that she
she takes on that role a bit more and
she uh is very comfortable obviously
with Miles and everything as well and um
they work really well together the three
of them
um
[Music]
and it's hard it's hard it's hard to
talk about without giving things away
yeah yeah
so many surprises oh man
I I think I think it's just you know
there's a reason why we wanted Yuri
Laura and najiel here because they are a
team they are you know they complement
each other really well not just what's
going on in the superhero world but
what's happening in their lives and I
think that's why you know I mean even
we're shooting our scenes we're all kind
of working together as a team and
figuring out how do we put this game
together and I know I we couldn't be
working with better people like I love
these people they're awesome
every day that we got to shoot and it
was all three of us
it was just so much fun on set you guys
it was just yeah people talk about
chemistry and there's something magical
that happens when these three get
together
um you know the the air changes uh it's
it's really any any beyond the scenes
BTS funny moments it's God's sin you
know it's uh well I even think about
when we cast everybody originally go
back real quick I know we're talking
about Spider-Man 2 but I remember you
know when we brought Naji in for for
Miles we Yuri was already cast and we
did this we did two scenes when the the
moment at the funeral when Peak goes up
to Miles and then also the part where
Miles Reveals His power to Pete for the
first time and we just knew right there
and I remember remember Laura coming in
for MJ
and we had like three scenes we're gonna
do and I remember they just they were
walking together and they said two lines
I said that's it she's just she's the
proper casting her so I just think that
we knew
we had such a great group and then we
would always say every day on stage we
would say just like what do you want to
do where do you want to take it and I
think you know they made the game better
than we ever could imagine it could be
so I thank them for that powerful thank
you Brian
well we love that we love the powerful
three I love Spider-Man we love modern
morale as a Spider-Man and we love Mary
Jane but there's somebody else that we
can't forget about on this panel of the
Venom of the minimum
Tony Todd it's truly an honor to have
you on the panel right now
well um I'm not really
Tony Todd I was sitting here I'm an AI
no uh you know I've been a I've been a
gamer since um High School I mean I I
grew went to college hustling pinball
and ping pong and I think I go back with
gaming systems all the way to in
television do Dreamcast through the
early you know and I I collect consoles
so yes you know I started as an actor
the voice over real came to me through
DC uh one character led to another Zoom
led to dark side and then some other
stuff and then all of a sudden I get a
call from Insomniac to
to test drive Venom and I gotta say it's
been the most exciting voice over
Journey that I've had to date yeah
I'm right uh they're uh can you just
talk about the the casting of this I
know is there a story or something along
how how this happened oh yeah there um
so I remember we we cast a lot of the
characters pretty quickly like obviously
we had you know miles Peter uh MJ
um and then early early we actually like
right before covet I think we cast
Craven and I knew I was putting off
Venom I was just putting it off I was
like
I know there's already you know there's
gonna be so many opinions what people
and I know I was scared of death and I
remember uh Patrick our dialogue um lead
was asking me like what are you looking
for and I said I don't know and then I
remember
just happened to be on the internet one
day and I was uh listening to one of the
I think it was the Candyman uh uh the
new Candyman trailer and I heard Tony
and I was like
get like a Tony tot that would be the
one and then a couple weeks go by I
don't think anything about it and
Patrick messages me and goes you're not
gonna believe this
Tony Todd's interested and I remember he
sent it real quick tape in and it was
like sorry Tony it was really bad like
audio quality but he took like three
lines and I was like that's it
please hire him please whatever he wants
give it to him and uh
you all know based on what you heard
it's it's he's incredible you brought
you brought it to a a mocap session a
pcap session and you're like dude listen
to this yeah we yeah we get on stage
everyone's whispering to us Tony's here
is here we're freaking out no we you
know we we have such a we have a
wonderful we you know there's you know
there's four of us here from insomnic
but we have so many Islamic people
putting so much work through this game
and I again just want to say if they're
somehow listeners somehow thank you for
all the work that you guys are putting
into it right now it's it's incredible
the work they're doing
it's just you know you know I call I
call insomnac my second family because
we just put so much into this and you
can imagine when you're in your family
everybody has opinions right and I think
it's probably the only decision I've
ever made being a creative director in
10 years where I just said Tony taught
me venom and everybody said yes so
um and uh it's just uh it's been you
know I mean go into those vo sessions
and just listening to Tony even when we
did the first the first the trailer when
he said yes we will I was like oh God
you know and uh yeah it's it's been
awesome yeah yeah as soon as I heard
Tony got cast I was like oh sign me up
like that's money and ever since then
now we were here and Tony's here it's
incredible and so my next question
though for for you uh John is can you
just talk a little bit about Venom's
motivations and his personality in this
and and what why is he so important to
The Narrative of this game well uh yeah
I mean
Venom is a symbiote right um and I think
the the thing that
um a lot of symbiote stories have in
common and the reason why I think we we
connect with them really well is that
it's it's a simple human story we we all
have a Darkness inside of us right
um and even you for front row I know I
know
um even Laura Bailey has Darkness like
what if you're in traffic and you're in
the dark he's going to use your blinker
oh my god oh well yeah anyway
um so uh so we we kind of started with
that and and when you have somebody
um like Yuri or Peter Parker uh who has
such a great heart
um
and then you you put the Symbiote on top
of that it really brings out the the
dark parts of what Spider-Man is about
power and responsibility you heard jury
talk about it um a couple minutes ago
um and what happens in the story is that
that sense of responsibility starts to
go away right like we've we've built up
this this spider team um that works well
together but Peter Parker at some point
in in the story starts to think he can
do it all himself he's got this power
right he doesn't need his team uh
there's there's all this stuff to do in
the city
you know and he starts to to push people
away
um and and that's when you know miles
and and MJ you heard it in the trailer
you know there's something wrong with
Pete right
um and and so uh you know it's it's
really interesting when you bring the
Symbiote into you know these
relationships uh how it really
challenges them not just externally
because there's cool Powers you know
Ryan was talking about having that that
control in your hand oh my God it's
amazing
um but the the the people you love
around you
um yeah yeah and and with the the iconic
look Jacinda can you just talk about how
your approach was to just making it feel
like it's its own but still having that
Venom essence you know like you swole
he's got the the tech with him
so can you can you just talk about your
approaching with this
sure um so as John was saying the the
SIM
bi is normally an allegory for the
darkness within so when you're thinking
about a character like Venom you have to
think about everything that Venom is
that Spider-Man is in um so what are the
differences so if you look at the Venom
design obviously he's black and white he
doesn't have all the color of Spider-Man
he's got his white spider but it's his
very own unique white spider
he's got the claws
um he's got the the big body that's much
bigger than Spider-Man and then he's got
a mouthful of teeth
um and this is a funny distinction if
you think about Spider-Man because the
only way Spider-Man can express himself
is through his eyes his quips
um and his actions but Venom actually
has a a mouth so that introduces a whole
new thing to this design and one of the
first things I asked Brian when we
started on this game was I asked him
does does venom actually talk
because if Venom talks does he have lips
[Laughter]
I keep awake at night thinking about
these things
and then does he smile how much is he
talking does he use his mouth for
attacks so we have to really think about
things like that
and not only that but then because he's
made out of this symbiote material what
exactly is it and there's a fine line
between making Venom into a slime
monster
or making him into a tentacle monster
and the melts had a lot to do with it as
well so in in some ways we actually got
rid of some of the human anatomy and got
rid of the jaw hinge when he opens his
mouth because we want to make him look
semi-liquid
and you'll see this also when the
Symbiote doesn't have a host because we
have to make sure that the Symbiote
wasn't really drippy so we made a rule
that
um he doesn't drip right the Symbiote
doesn't drip because if he was he'd be
slime but if you strike the Symbiote
hard enough and you inflict enough
damage then yes you will see impact so
that's kind of how you thread the needle
between making him look liquidy or
semi-liquid and then the last thing
that's interesting is you know Dorian
talked about how swole he is
a really fine needle to thread as well
because you know we know he's buff but
how buff is too buff right because we
need to make sure he's really big
powerful intimidating but at the same
time he's also very Nimble as well and
he's fast so we did a bunch of sketches
where we had a wide range of body types
where you know sometimes he's huge and
sometimes he's really skinny and then
what made the most sense in terms of his
moveset and oh there you see they pulled
the concept
yeah so we were just like going really
wide going really skinny and it's
somewhere in the middle is what we
picked and this is what you see in our
our statue in the game as well so but
definitely a lot of uh like what he does
and what he represents informs his
character design
and you know what's so awesome about
working with everyone here not only is
everyone so thoughtful and puts in the
hours and scrutinizing and really
thinking what who are these characters
what do they represent
uh what I also love about the whole team
is very they're very respectful
of the core ingredients
um and and paying attention to where did
the characters come from and looking at
the source material but at the same time
everyone
um really has embraced the idea of but
let's take some chances Let's uh let's
do what the story dictates let's do what
uh the gameplay what feels right for the
gameplay so uh uh what what will be the
awesome wish fulfillment for the players
so it's that idea of completely
authentic but let's take some chances
let's try some things new so when you
play the game you're like wow
I know these characters but I've never
experienced them like this
and then that leads to surprises you
don't know where the story is going you
don't know uh what's going to happen and
so I just I just love it I just love it
the respect
uh but then the The Bravery to try new
things and make the story the characters
and the game their own absolutely I
think you guys have nailed the park on
that with these first two games and I
expect greatness from this one as well
you got to be great together that's what
the the line yeah so I had to check in
on Yuri a couple of times on stage y'all
so he really really goes into it you're
gonna be in for a treat I had to stop
like Yuri are you come on you good you
right you okay bring it back Gary bring
it back all right yeah man and just
speaking about the the the approach and
the design of a king Tony I'm coming
back to you can you talk about your
approach to bringing the voice of it to
life and how you approached it well I
had a lot of help in the booth uh shout
out to Chris who vocally directed us all
but she really made me dig deep you know
on the surface I could come up with it
but we tried to make
we wanted to make even though he's the
same yacht I needed to make him human
first if that makes any sense I mean
they had to be relatable and he had to
have an objective and uh and follow that
through I mean I come from the theater
so I'm in Masters in theater so every I
take every job whether it's voiceover TV
film
uh as a as a as a well-made script and
uh and we just we just went with the
flow for me venom was fun to do and I
wanted to make sure that there was a
joyous quality in his in his destruction
uh you know he's he he's he's he's only
here on Earth for a little bit and he's
going to move on somewhere else so I
wanted to make sure that he left that
impact of joy and uh tenacity and
deliciousness
I'm glad it was fun for you because it
scared the hell out of us
yeah it'd be funny when we were uh in
the recording booth because we would
record separately when we were doing
gameplay dialogue and every once in a
while Tony you would come and play in
our headphones before a line and it was
like oh God
I wouldn't expect it and it was
terrifying
and Tony coming back to you again I'm
not trying to break into Mike's stuff
uh can you just briefly uh talk about
the Lord kind of touched on this the
collaborative process with the other
cast members and really finding the your
voice with uh within this game well just
like Gloria said that my voice is in
their air the voices in my air every
time I uh every time I record it and I
had a lot of recording sessions so we
did like uh I think the assessments were
four hours at a time I won't tell you
how many there were but it was it was a
I live in another part of L.A and I had
to drive all the way to Burbank too to
lay it down but it was always it was
never a moment oh God I got to go away
and it was like oh God I'm so excited to
be able to craft this character and to
be a part of the whole Spider-Man family
and the Insomniac team and Playstation I
am Overjoyed sometimes I talk too much
I was working on another game and uh
anyway we're here now and uh wait to see
the joy and excitement of everybody and
this team and this fantastic franchise
and Brian I'll come back to you real
quick what was that like when you heard
Tony voice his lines for the first time
officially and what was that what was
your initial reaction
well first relief because I was like
okay we made the right choice for sure
um and I think then just general
excitement and I think
Tony is so talented that you know
sometimes depending on you know we have
so many different characters are so
different so many different actors you
know sometimes we're you know depending
on what the role calls for are we gonna
you know adjust the the way that they do
the line and you just let Tony be Tony
and you get magic and it's just I mean
and he did he mentioned uh Chris
Zimmerman our voice director who has
been with us since day one on the
Spider-Man franchise and she just does
an amazing job helping yeah shout out to
Chris Zimmerman yeah that's awesome she
does a great she does a great job of not
just directing our actors but also like
really going just diving into the
material and wanting to know what our
what the motivation for the care where
we are in the game like really
understanding I think that just you know
in her working with Tony as Tony
mentioned has just brought out the best
and you know to me is going to be you
know a really signature performance of
Venom that you've seen we cannot wait
amen yeah and Tony coming back to you
what was your uh what was your initial
reaction when you saw the we saw your
your your character you saw your voice
coming out of it for the first time like
finish polished version of it well you
know I grew up an only kid so I'm a nerd
at height I played Monopoly by myself I
did road racing Slot Cars by myself and
I won
um so you know I
uh it was like a gift come true to be
able to um
to submit myself into whole voice over
family and world and meet new friends
and uh conquests and I I'm still
pinching myself because I'm a gamer and
I'm telling you I can't wait for this
Monumental Masterpiece to drop
that's right Sizzle
90 days
90 days I believe so 99. oh my god oh
yeah we're shutting it down October's
right around the corner for the next
couple weeks oh yeah we'll just make
sure oh yeah we're playing it oh yeah
and so those parents we apologize
Tony we have another section coming up
but I I be remiss if I didn't ask you
can you do the iconic we are Venom line
for for everybody
bring us all out what do you want no
okay
oh
Venom
[Applause]
all right well I think we got some some
special surprises coming up for you guys
I think the next thing we want to talk
about is the collector's edition statue
that we have here on this table right
here so Brian I'm Pat can I don't know I
already told him I'm taking it home so
you cannot have it but but uh Brian I'm
gonna have to fight me for it it's a
list coming to you first can you just
talk about what this this showcases and
and and how it you know gives a little
hint to the game so
I think it really represents what this
game is about you know it you know I
said you know I've said in previous
interviews I've talked about you know
it's called Spider-Man 2 for a reason
because we have two iconic characters
um in this in this great piece of art
but also is it's going to take two
Spider-Man to take on something so
powerful something that they've never
been able did nothing come their way I
mean you know if you look at you know
whether Doc Ock in the in the first game
and then Tinker in Miles Morales like
venomizel is literally a whole different
beast and I think that
you know it kind of represents what this
game is about and just the just the
hopefully the epicness the you know that
we're gonna hopefully you know we want
to deliver and uh
I look at this I'm really really proud
just like I am about the game that we're
making so yeah I can see people like I'm
like two feet away from it I'm again I'm
taking this home after this taking on
Security's gonna try to stop me but it's
all good but Jacinda I'm coming to you
though can you just talk about the the
design of this and your approach to that
right and we've
truly about
the characters fighting Darkness right
Darkness suppressed within Darkness
without so it was really important when
we were doing the statue that you may
not know what the outcome of this
fight's gonna be so it was really
important that Venom looks powerful
um and both of the Spider-Man look
powerful and they're engaging each other
and you don't know who's gonna win and I
think that's a really part a big part of
the the success of the statue that and
the fact that it's giant Mungus
when I when I got the sample sent to me
the box was so big I was shocked to
unbox it so I can't wait to get this in
the hands of fans as well and this is
available for pre-order on PS direct and
if you are not in the US you can check
your local retailers and local stores uh
with that being said I I'm Brian why are
you putting on gloves right now like
that's of these yeah what what what is
that for well Dorian before we I think
we should play the video I think we
should play the video let's go and play
that video real quick
miles I need your help what is this
stuff
wait Pete I got an idea
nice one more time on three one two
three
[Applause]
[Music]
what
yeah
the beautiful
Spiderman 2 PlayStation 5. oh my God
I didn't know about that I didn't know
they didn't show me that before we came
out
I know what they were doing
wow all right well here we go like
Marvel's they keep everything so tight
lip I found out about this five minutes
before we came out here that's how
serious they are so Brian can you can
you speak to this epic amazing
beautifulness right here this has been
one of the biggest secrets throughout
the entire development of the game that
we were gonna have a the console and the
dual shock um so it's I know we're
pretty pumped I mean I think you know we
talked about the Symbiote playing a big
role obviously it plays a big role here
in design of the console and we think we
think PlayStation for uh going above and
beyond with the design of it I know I
just worked really closely with
everybody on on the design of it and
I I'm pretty pumped man
I'm just I'm Starstruck right now really
close I can't you know you can't touch
it and Jacinda can you just elaborate on
the design elements of this and this is
how beautiful it is like what's up with
that now
what is up with this just
statue um the theme of the console is
basically the the Symbiote takeover
um so again we left a bit of red on the
console and on the controller because
the question is who's going to win will
the darkness win or will the light win
um and again it's up in the air and this
why is there so much symbiote on there
Jacinda
[Laughter]
Brian can you I think we have a little
bit more details on the the not just the
this PS5 but is there a couple more
details you want to talk about with uh
where people can buy this or how they
can get yeah so you can actually start
pre-ordering uh next Friday so the 28th
you can start pre-ordering yeah
so I know I'll be in pre-order I'm I'm
already or I'm just going to take this
one with me
and also uh so last thing if you if you
guys do want to pre-order now make sure
to get that go to playstation.blog you
can pick it up then pre-order on when it
does debut um I know I am and so that's
pretty much wraps up most of what we
want to talk about but we do have some
uh one more thing we want to just reveal
we got some Mondo posters we want to
talk all things Mondo but before we do
that I just want to say thank you again
to the incredible panelists that we have
out here yes yes thank y'all for having
us absolutely thank you thank you oh we
got we got a Commando we've got that
beautiful Mondo so if you do you want to
pick that up uh if we want to throw that
back on the screen real quick you want
to throw it up on there if you if you do
want to pick that up you can go to the
marble booth for an opportunity to pick
it up there there's they're there now
and then you can also have a chance to
have all the incredible panelists up
here sign it so if you want to head over
to yeah it's something serious so you
want to if you want to go get that make
sure right after this panel head over to
the Marvel Booth it's happening able to
pick it up but well with that being said
hey how about for Dorian doing a great
job with this yeah how about that
[Applause]
how about for ASL interpreter over here
who was working overtime
[Applause]
yeah
I love that I love that over there it's
so incredible but I'm just honored yeah
at the beginning like your boy's been a
spidey fan all his life I've grown up
with this franchise grown up with these
comic books grown up with these
characters and to be out here talking to
so many great fans that love the game
just as much as me it's a surreal moment
so no I don't want to you know I'm up
here getting emotional like Uncle Ben
just died or something but like
it's a real cool moment but with that
being said you know let's let's Also
let's let's get back to the Mondo poster
so you can pick those up you know I'm
you know I'm trying to keep it on
schedule trying to keep it keep it
everything you keep everything flowing
but you can you know it's a another
module collaboration we also do have is
the the vinyl soundtrack of the game
with the amazing score from composer
John pasina Pacino I'm messing up his
name but you know uh you can also get
that vinyl as well so it's pretty cool
but Marvel Spider-Man 2 arrives early on
October 20th so make sure to pick that
up if you if you haven't already
pre-ordered make sure to get pre-order
make sure to go support this game but
yes all all in all that being said I
want to say thank you again to this
incredible panel thank you guys so much
for all your hard work
and also
and also before we go follow us on all
social medias y'all see any new
platforms any new things coming up
because we'll be traveling around until
October all right so follow our
Instagrams mine is n-a-j-i-t-o
gotta get that plug in our name
yeah Yuri why are you guys
don't know I my family calls me that
it's a family name I don't know it's
they got ragging my family man
sees the symbol I love weirdness
symbiote is coming out I told you I told
you he doesn't leave I can do anything I
want now I better get ready man because
it's going to be crazy October 20th bro
okay all right guys I can't even imagine
we're greater together yeah
Ryan we have a little bit more time can
you talk about the the chaos you have to
deal with between Yuri energy throughout
this whole process real quick I mean
it's hard to get mad at them
I mean I think because I mean not to get
they just we trust them implicitly with
this character it's just like you know
you know hopefully Bill's talked about
you know letting letting us work on this
franchise that I think
we can say we've all been fans since we
were little kids and you know we talk
about you know it's cliche to say but in
ways we feel a lot of responsibility to
to make this in everyday weather where
you know it's you know we're working
talking each other over slack or we're
on the performance capture stage or just
even text each other in a random
Saturday afternoon like we have the best
jobs in the world like we I mean we get
to be big kids on set to be
honestly he's like what's your job I'm
like I'm just a big kid yeah absolutely
it's the best
as Brian said and as everyone has used
the phrase it does all come down to
power and responsibility our our power
if you will is we man we get to work
with all these great people so talented
we get to work on we get to make a video
game like just that is awesome and we
get to now make the Spider-Man game in
games of our dreams so the power is wow
we we have these great characters these
amazing creators to work with uh and our
responsibility all of us is make
something awesome that's right that's
right
y'all get ready
well I think that we we were pretty much
wrapped up everything we we hit
everything on the head like anybody else
got any last minute things they want to
throw out here before before we wrap up
this panel anything else I just want to
say thank you for all the amazing
support every tweet every note we get we
read them all
um and we really appreciate it and uh
we're working really hard for the next
couple months to finish this and deliver
the game that you all are hoping for so
just thank you again yes thank y'all man
yeah oh yeah you got to give a gotta
give a shout out to the Insomniac
Community team because the way I I see
it because I'm one of them I see the
fans out there I see how y'all y'all hit
them up for new news or anything like oh
y'all been y'all been y'all been
bullying them a little bit but but
respectful respectfully bullying because
I I see the passion as well so got a
shout out to the the insomnia Community
team because that's a that's a tough job
but anybody else got anything to say
before we brought this up Yuri you look
like you got something to say uh there's
only one room for one bully on this
stage
oh
no no I already did it all right so I
got it out of the way
listen listen
I've been wanting to say you know we got
bully low and thaw like I wanted to say
that this whole time so I um I had to
shoot her shoes so there we go
man but all in all that's it for this uh
that's it for this Comic-Con San Diego
panel for Marvel Spider-Man
[Applause]
biggest game of the year biggest game of
the century I'm I'm high for it so thank
you guys again we have a we have one
more little trailer for you guys
that's right you know how Marvel does
come on now come on now so so get ready
let's stay to the end of the credits
yeah come on I'm not bad I should have
should have teeth that out for you guys
before I said bye but here we go
no if you need me I'm just a call away
what the hell's going on with me he's
not himself
thank you guys thank you guys for coming
out make sure to head over to the Marvel
Booth to get a sign Mondo poster and you
know yeah be great together baby love
y'all thank y'all so much man
PlayStation